wir haben eine neue besucherin hier in
unserem open office dorothee bär
staatsministerin für digitales im
kanzleramt vor bevor wir zum ernsten
thema kommen schon schöner hier also im
kanzleramt oder also schöner weiß ich
nicht aber es ist total beeindruckend
dann doch dass das openoffice mal nach
berlin umgezogen ist also habt ihr
beziehungsweise auch die kulissenbauer
es sehr gut hinbekommen wenn sie jetzt
als ministerin für digitales auf das
schauen was dort gerade in den usa
passiert wir sehen donald trump bietet
eigentlich alle zwei minuten
das ist ja eigentlich eine vorbildliche
nutzung der neuen medien oder na ja man
sieht ja auch wie six auf twitter
entwickelt und auch das quasi gefühlt
fast jeder tweet wendig jeder zweite
tweet von ihm dann auch tatsächlich
gespart wird oder auch mit dem
warnhinweis belegt wird es ist natürlich
eine ganz neue dimension wenn wirklich
ein staatschef der den neuen medien
nutzt dann trotzdem auch noch mal vom
nachrichtendienst eingeordnet wird also
das gibt's zumindest ansonsten in europa
nicht bei polizei sieht das richtig dass
twitter da eingreift und sagt passen sie
auf hier aufpassen
ist es nicht auch gefährlich dass so ein
konzern diese macht hat sozusagen da in
so einem wahlkampf am ende auch
einzugreifen
also jetzt wird ja auch nicht in den
wahlkampf eingegriffen sondern jetzt
geht es ja um die auszählung man muss
sich natürlich ganz genau anschauen was
wir den menschen da auch zumuten was wir
ihnen auch zutrauen wir sind auch
permanent am kämpfen gegen fake news
wir versuchen schon ständig auch
natürlich bei nutzerinnen und nutzer
darauf hinzuweisen nicht alles ungefragt
zu teilen auch mal nachzudenken
vielleicht auch mal faktencheck zu
machen und deswegen ist es schon eine
gefährliche entwicklung wenn man sich
nicht darauf verlassen kann dass auch
politikerinnen und politiker nach besten
wissen und gewissen auch soziale
netzwerke nutzen
insofern wäre es natürlich schöner wenn
es nicht von twitter notwendig wäre aber
in dem fall wenn man sieht wie auch die
tweets rausgehauen werden und das auch
bewusst unwahrheit gesagt werden wo sind
ist es junge wohin ungehaltener sich der
letzte tweet war hören auf zu zählen das
ist noch kein unwahrheit oder der letzte
tweet war es gehört auch zu zählen genau
das habe ich auch gerade noch gesehen
aber bei manchen dingen sich als
wahlsieger auszurufen obwohl der wein
noch überhaupt nicht vorbei ist das ist
schon mehr als kritisch
welche macht haben die sozialen medien
dann auch wir haben immer wieder jetzt
bilder gesehen von vor einem transporter
die auf die straßen gehen
das auch nicht überall friedlich und
natürlich lässt sich dann schnell
vermuten dass es an diesen tweets liegt
und also wie viel macht haben sie und
vor allem ist es auch gut dass dann ein
paar worte auf dem kurznachrichtendienst
so viele menschen bewegen können na ja
grundsätzlich ist es mal gut dass wir
auch als politikerinnen und politiker
ganz interaktiv auch mit bürgerinnen und
bürgern ins gespräch kommen können das
ist ganz wichtig dieses niederschwellige
auch der ansprechpartner zu sein wenn
natürlich jetzt das merkt man ja auch
dann bei den tritt nicht nur was die
rasanz betrifft sondern auch die
intensität und in capital lettern und so
das ausrufezeichen als rudeltier zu
benutzen da merkt man natürlich das
nerven auch mittlerweile extrem blank
liegen grundsätzlich ist es was
positives aber genauso wie sehen messer
positiv und negativ benutzen können
merkt man es halt besser einen spitz
auch an dieser stelle aber bevor wir
gleich zu unserem kollegen peter
telefons kanzleramt einmal schalten
wollen die frage sie sind ja die ganze
zeit mit der kanzlerin zusammen dort im
kanzleramt wie hat sie die wahl
wahrgenommen sagt sie dort vor ihrem
ipad und hat das immer wieder refresh
oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen
wie nimmt eine kanzlerin das war
wir sind tatsächlich nicht zusammen
keiner von uns weil wir uns sehr strenge
regeln halten dass er zwei häuser
außerhalb des kabinetts versucht
wirklich jeder in seinem eigenen büro zu
sein beziehungsweise auch am 10
wir haben unsere mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter so weit wie möglich alle ins
home office geschickt aber sie haben wir
sicherlich kontakt mit der kanzlerin wie
nehmen sie das wahr wie schaut sie auf
die wahl wie sie hofft sie dass donald
trump am ende verliert ich glaube dass
fragen sie am besten selber was ist denn
ihre persönliche meinung dazu wie dieses
kopf an kopf rennen am ende ausgeht und
vielleicht auch ihre eigene hoffnung wie
das ganze ausgeht
sehr spannend ist es von den staaten was
noch übrig ist also ich hab selber einen
onkel der aus pennsylvania kommt
deswegen ist es natürlich ganz
aufregende der gewinn
ich habe ihn nicht gefragt aber ich
könnte mir denken was er gewählt haben
könnte aber auch da gilt natürlich das
wahlgeheimnis aber das spannende ist er
hat eine sehr sehr große familie ganz
viele schwestern und brüder die alle
noch erlebt in deutschland alle anderen
liegen noch in pennsylvania
aber was nehmen sie da war das ist ja
sehr sehr spannend weil und pennsylvania
wird so viel gekämpft
da auch die familie gespalten was sagen
diejenigen die donald trump will spanien
der ist es noch bei meiner eigenen
gastfamilie auch weil ich habe in
illinois mein high school abschluss
gemacht und wir leben so an der grenze
mit meiner gastfamilie zu disc on sind
also das heißt das ferienhaus ist auch
in wisconsin ein teil meiner gastfamilie
ist auch nach des konzerns gezogen und
dann nehme ich das auch innerhalb der
familie natürlich war dass es da
diejenigen gibt in der familie die auch
auf der obama campaign waren die hillary
clinton unterstützt haben so lange her
was das jetzt genau und jetzt eben die
jetzt auch trump unterstützt haben auch
beim letzten mal gegen hillary clinton
und das spannende ist schon zumindest in
meiner gastfamilie dass die sich der
politisch sehr stark unterscheiden dass
es ja auch viele gibt in der großfamilie
der gastfamilie die eben auch
außenbereich der hand der fischer kommen
die auch das gefühl haben dass es ihnen
in den letzten vier jahren besser
gegangen ist viele die das aber gar
nicht so sehen genau das gegenteil und
trotzdem spaltet die familie nicht so im
vergleich dazu die wenn ich mir jetzt
nicht vorstellen könnte dass sich jetzt
bei uns jemand im bundestag dass ich
jetzt ein grüner abgeordneter mit
jemandem aus der afg verheiratet also so
ist es tatsächlich nicht sondern politik
spielt eine rolle aber es wird nicht so
politisch diskutiert in dem details wie
es oft in deutschland der fall ist muss
ich einfach eine ausgangsfrage man
zurückkehren was ihre hoffnung für den
wahlausgang
meine hoffnung ist dass derjenige der
unterliegt auch demjenigen der gewinn
gratulieren kann und dass man auch so
ein demokratisches ergebnis einfach
akzeptiert weil ansonsten dieses lange
das magma jetzt schon wie lange es
dauert mit den auszählungen und dieses
lange dauern hat natürlich immer ganz
viel potenzial so wie sie es gerade
beschrieben haben dass menschen dann
unruhig werden auf die straße gehen die
wollen ein ergebnis
ich kenne ganz viele auch die wirklich
durchgängig seit dienstag sind überhaupt
nicht mehr geschlafen haben weil sie das
ganze eben auch so verfolgen fielen in
den sieg nicht einverstanden
ich habe auch ganz wenig geschlafen ich
brauche auch nicht so viel schlaf weil
man natürlich sehr aufgeregt ist und es
gab jede wahlnacht auch in den letzten
malen immer verfolgt weil usa ist halt
einfach ein herzens land für mich
persönlich aber eben auch für unser land
und weil mir die transatlantische
beziehung extrem am herzen liegt und
ganz ganz wichtig aber können sie das
konkret sagen welchen der beiden
kandidaten sie die daumen drücken ich
akzeptierte demokratische ergebnisse
natürlich ist es so dass wir
grundsätzlich politiker lieber sind die
frauen respektieren wir sind bild und
wir liefert dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren